you have some baby news Congrats yes
thank you
there's another big addition to the
family
a lot of people may or may not know that
I had issues getting pregnant you know
when me and my husband got married so we
had did the IVF treatment and we got our
son aged he's three now and we wanted to
have another child we still had two more
embryos from that and because I had a
high-risk pregnancy you know we were
trying to figure out okay what's the
best way to go about this and we decided
to go with a surrogate yeah and she
decided to help me in my husband amazing
I loved it cuz you're you're actually
documenting it on this show right yes
and I think that's really important I
have many friends that have suffered
from like trying to have children try
and try and drain and can't do it and
like it's a very important thing to be
confident and comfortable saying like
look my body it wasn't made for my body
by the way was not made for pregnancy I
was hospitalized it was horrible also
not made for me it's hard if your body
if it doesn't take it yeah like so hard
on you so it's an amazing thing I think
it's so awesome that you're like sharing
that that's a very important where you
go into the will you be there for the
delivery sure I mean a lot of what
you'll see on the show this season like
you'll see we're going to doctors
appointments together we're you know
just that whole process because I don't
think anybody actually showed it because
a lot of people are quiet about it like
honestly I really didn't even tell
anybody that we were expecting a child
and so the show announced that it was
airing a new season because I didn't
really know how to share that with a lot
of my friends either
yeah like a lot of my friends were like
wait a minute you're having a baby you
know yeah it was like really crazy to
them but at the same time I didn't
really want to hear anybody else's
opinion at first yeah and so to do it
you yeah to do it on the show it's like
a big deal because it's like you don't
know how people are going to comment
because you know the first thing you're
getting a beautiful child who the hell
cares what they say that is true
[Applause]
like honestly I like that is a really
touchy subject with my friends that's
like really hard like for a woman
especially like you it's such a sense of
failure you feel like we can't do it so
it's really cool that you're open about
it thank you the with my first child my
Riley's you know if it was in my 20s you
know I didn't have to really try hard
but then you know later in life when I
met my husband I'm thinking that
everything was just gonna happen and it
didn't mm-hm so I think you know a lot
of women start to have that struggle as
they get older mm-hmm yeah I didn't have
my kids I was in my 30s it was oh and I
didn't ever look like that definitely
didn't um I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my YouTube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this